well the heads of facebook google and
twitter are being grilled by u.s
congressional members on capitol hill
today
lawmakers have criticized the executives
for the role that their companies often
play in the spread of misinformation
today's hearing is the first
since the u.s capitol was stormed by
pro-trump rioters back in january
the hearing could lead to steps to make
the tech giants more accountable
for the content that they host on their
platforms
all right for morning i'm joined by dw's
chief technology correspondent janos
delker y'all know so you've been
following these hearings
uh has it been a true grilling
well brent it has i mean the three of
them are really
feeling the heat and you can feel the
frustration of lawmakers through the
screen
that started with the opening statement
of the chairman of the committee
who said and i quote him that this
information was one of the biggest
reasons for people in the us not to get
vaccinated at the moment
and he added you can fix this but you
chose not to
this was very much echoed by other
lawmakers who said for example
we want no more empty promises we've
heard them again and again
and you know this is the fourth online
hearing of big tech
since the beginning of the coronavirus
pandemic
and there were several before that and i
watched quite a number of them
but this level of frustration today is
really extraordinary
and you can feel that in the questions
that are being asked today
yeah i want you to take a look um at an
exchange from today's opening
question session and then we'll talk
about it take a look
uh if i ask you a yes or no question i'm
just looking for a yes or no so please
respond appropriately
i want to start by asking all three of
you
if your platform bears some
responsibility for disseminating
disinformation
related to the election and the stop the
steel movement that led to the attack on
the capital just a yes or no answer
mr zuckerberg chairman i think our
responsibility is to build systems that
can help
i just want to yes
we always feel a deep sense of
responsibility but i think we worked
hard
uh this election effort was one of our
most substantive efforts is that a yes
or no
uh it's a complex question mr dorsey
yes but you also have to take into
consideration a broader ecosystem
it's not just about the technology
platforms we use
thank you all right i mean that's
amazing he was struggling to get one of
them to say yes or no
what do you make of that are these
executives are they afraid of
telling the truth or is there something
else at play here
well you know i would say as a matter of
fact it is remarkable that
with jack dorsey of twitter for the
first time a top tech executive
acknowledged that his platform had some
sort of
influence on the riot that happened at
the capitol
and i think this also really illustrates
that this is
a turning point you know before january
6th people knew
that online hate can spill into real
life violence i mean we've seen that in
myanmar for example where for years
facebook was used to incite hatred
against the rohingya
minority but those things happen outside
of the u.s and what happened on january
6th
really hit close to home for u.s
lawmakers
and you know now they seem to be getting
serious about regulating
or some kind of regulation for the
liability of platforms
yeah i mean dorsey said yes but he also
qualified it which is
part of the problem um with questioning
these ceos
so if we're talking about regulation
what do you think tougher regulation is
going to look like
well i think you know what's key to
understand is that in the u.s unlike in
germany for example
social media companies currently
essentially
enjoy immunity for what's being said or
done on their platforms and this
dates back to regulation known as
section 230 which is
you know was introduced back in 1996 so
at the time when all those companies who
were there today were
just founded and you know what's up for
debate now and also during the hearing
is
really much you know how can you update
or even
repeal that bill you know us by
u.s president joe biden has called for
fully repealing it
um the companies of course don't like
that idea they are arguing in favor of
reforming it
but the meeting today suggests that you
know some kind of momentum
is building four tougher rules for
liability
for social media platforms in the us as
well but make no mistake it's far from
certain how that's going to look like
yeah there is the fear too if the
companies have to be liable for the
content on their
platforms it could be the end of the
internet as we know it
we will see vw's chief technology
correspondent yanno stelker
yanovs thank you